>> David, that's a good point. One way of capturing the meaning of that story in
terms of these primitive actions is in, to use the move object primitive action.
So, here about the object being moved and the mover of the object is the same,
I. So, I am moving myself one place to another place. And
the nearest point here is that these primitive actions will be able to capture
the meaning of some sentences in a very simple, logical, intuitive sense. And
for some other sentences, it might be a little bit more involved. So let us see
how this primitive actions may actually help an AI agent make sense of stories.
So here is the first thing we can do. Recall there were large number of stories,
each expressed by one sentence. Ashok ate a frog, Ashok devoured a frog and
so on. So now, ate, devoured, consumed, ingest, partook. We can think that
each one of them really is an instance of a primitive action called ingest.
Here's the primitive action Ingest. So Ashok ingested a frog here,
Ashok ingested a frog here, Ashok ingested a frog here.
Well, superficially these particular sentences are different.
In terms of their deep meaning, the deep meaning is pretty much the same. But
it's true of course that the world may have a slightly different interpretation
than dining. The [INAUDIBLE] might be something that I ravish with my hands for
example, and dining might involve fine dining with silverware. nevertheless,
ingest captures the basic meaning of these sentences. What is the basic meaning?
The basic meaning again is that Ashok is an agent.
Frog is the object that is getting eaten, ingested. Initially the frog was
outside Ashok's body, and probably dead or alive. We don't know its state.
After the ingestion has occurred, a devoured has occurred,
a consumed has occurred, the frog is inside Ashok's body, and it's dead. And
further, that Ashok probably is happy at the end of this particular ingestion.
And where is all of that knowledge coming from? It's buried inside the frame for
ingest. So each of these primitive actions has a frame corresponding to it.
And we have come across frame many times already in the class, so
by now you should know what it means. And the frame has a large number of slots
like agent, co-agent, object, beneficiary and so on, and those slots deal with
still a difficult situations and have default values already put in there. So
when a sentence comes like, Ashok ate a frog, then the verb ate here, pulls out
the primitive action ingest, and the frame for this primitive action and
the processing becomes top down, and they start thinking, where will Ashok go?
Where will frog go? Who is the agent? Who is the object? And so on.